hello everyone my name is walter osser
i'm the senior business unit manager for
individual pharmacology at the jackson
laboratory
and today i'm going to be talking about
pdx models for oncology research and
pre-clinical prediction
now in the talk today i hope to
communicate sort of three main points
the first of them is how these models
are made and why they're made
secondly why the research community is
so excited about using these models and
then conclude with some examples of work
by oncologists and oncology researchers
using these models today
now in this webinar format you can
submit uh questions on the q a box on
your screen and at the end of the talk
i'll try to get to those as i can i
expect my presentation to last about 30
minutes
and then after that i'll move on to
questions
first a word or two about the jackson
laboratory the laboratory was
established a long time ago about 85
years ago now and it's located in bar
harbor maine
now uh it it was really established to
focus on mouse models to understand
basic biology and to understand human
disease and it's grown very
significantly over the years today we
have more than 1200
employees there uh 47 faculty members
and it's a large mouse production
facility as well
also part of our charter is to be an
international training center and that's
actually become very important there are
a significant number of nobel prize
winners who've passed through the
laboratory either as high school or
summer students so it's a
very significant part of what we do
about 10 years ago we established a west
coast presence and that's at the
sacramento california facility and
that's where i work
this is probably the world's largest
facility
for producing mice at the highest health
status
and it's also where we perform the
individual pharmacology services
uh
and our pdx program so all the pdx
models we'll talk about today are
created at the sacramento facility
very recently only a couple weeks ago we
opened a third location in north america
and this is a jackson laboratory for
genomic medicine and it's on the
university of connecticut health
sciences campus in farmington and this
sort of closes the circle for us we were
really focused on mouse genetics earlier
on then on
pdx models were incorporating both mice
and human tissue and now this facility
is really focused
uh completely on human genomics
and human genetic medicine so we're very
excited about this new facility
now when people think of jackson
laboratory they really think of jax mice
and that's because the jackson
laboratory is an nih-funded resource to
provide mouse models to the research
community
uh
there are over 7 000 strains of mice
that we maintain and we're shipping this
year almost 3 000 mice to the research
community the real cornerstone of our
program though is this third point here
is genetic quality maintaining the
highest genetic quality impurity
and the highest animal health status
and we are really truly the leaders
worldwide in animal health status
now let's talk about
pdx now and the whole pdx concept came
about because of the problem that's
demonstrated in this slide
today only about five percent of drugs
and inner clinical trials actually make
it through to approval
and what that tells us is the
preclinical models that are used to
develop these drugs just aren't doing
the job they should be doing
we're losing about 30 percent of drugs
due to attrition uh because of lack of
efficacy
we lose another 30 percent of drugs due
to lack of safety
and
this has just created a huge problem for
developers of drugs worldwide and really
is the driving force behind the
development of new preclinical models
and really the pdx model is among the
most exciting of the new generation of
preclinical models and that's really
because it does a much better job of
predicting
how a drug will work in a human system
now mouse models have been used as
pre-clinical models for many many years
and what's shown on this slide is the
classic xenograph model using a nude
mouse
so if you look on the left of this side
this is a nude mouse
that is harboring a tumor in this case
it's an ncf7 human breast tumor cell
line that's been injected into the mouse
under the skin and has grown into a
sizable tumor that you can see
now after treatment you see the tumor
can fully uh regress and disappear
the problem with these models are really
twofold first one is the need to implant
a br a cell line
these cell lines have been established
and grown in plastic for years sometimes
decades
and they really represent a pure cell
population that has little
relationship to the natural
heterogeneity of a tumor
in a human body where you have many
types of cells
basically that now in terms of the the
second issue with these this has to do
with the mouse itself nude mice are very
good at supporting uh these established
cell lines but their immune system is
such they typically will not support the
engraftment of more complex tissue such
as
real tumor tissue
and if we're going to study the
heterogeneity of real tumor tissue we
really need to be studying that tissue
itself not some purified cell line
now in order to come up with a mouse
that will support the engraftment of
human tissue you've got to step back and
look at the immune system that's what
this cartoon does for us
so when i think about the mouse model of
the and the immune system on the left
hand side we see the innate immune
system where we have the complement
system the macrophages and this is sort
of your first line of defense
um in the immune
system and then on the right side the
blue circles we have the adaptive immune
system things like t lymphocytes and
antibodies and the coordination of the
two systems through the cytokine
signaling
so this is a cartoon of an immune system
but when we're thinking about mouse
models you can also think of each of
these
uh circles as an obstacle to the
effective
graftman of human tissue and so what
we're going to do when we create a mouse
model that will accept human tumors is
we need to [ __ ] this immune system as
much as we can
and this is a project that's been going
on for years in our laboratory and many
others
but the latest state of the art is
something we call the nsg mouse and its
immune system is shown in this cartoon
where we've basically knocked out almost
all of the innate immune system except
for the granulocytes
we've knocked out almost the entire
adaptive immune system except for a
little bit of dendritic cell activity
and we've severely crippled the cytokine
signaling
so because the mouse is so immune
deficient it will accept a whole variety
of different human tissues including
solid tumors and liquid tumors like
leukemia and not reject those and so
this is the so-called nod skid mouse
which is the basis of all the pdx models
that i'll discuss today
as shown here the nod skid mouse or the
nsg mouse it's
deficient in t cells b cells natural
killer cells and very importantly it has
a long lifespan
uh as long as you maintain it in a
relatively sterile environment these
mice will live out easily past a year
and are very very healthy in fact and so
they do support the engraftment of a
whole variety of different tumors
and
and cell types so everything i'll talk
about today now
the all the pdx models are based upon
this sort of amazing nsg mouse
background
now when we are
creating these pdx models the most
important step is the first
that is getting the human tumor from the
clinician from the operating room and
getting it and grafted into a mouse
within 24 hours is our cut off and so
you can imagine the logistics there are
difficult and we've worked very hard
with a number of uh cancer centers
nationwide to put this network in place
where we can get the fresh tissue
directly from the operating suite
directly to our facility into the mouse
within 24 hours
now in our hands we find that just about
half of the tumors that we bring in
will engraft
successfully into the nsg mouse it
depends somewhat on the stage of the
tumor and how aggressive it is and also
the the type of tumor
for example certain types of breast
tumors require
um
estradiol for example and
you need to be able when grafting a
system that has the hormones needed but
in general we find about 50 percent as a
rule of thumb
now once those tubers have demonstrated
successfully and graft that triggers us
to do our characterization panel so we
do a variety of different genomic
characterization technique techniques
such as gene expression arrays we do
copy number variation analysis
we do a lot of
sequencing of specific genes to look for
mutations
and then we then we
place all those data into a database
we also then take that tumor we take
part of it and we cryobank it
but we take the other part and we expand
it so typically the tumor will be
then engrafted and what we call the p0
core heart shown here is for mice
typically it could be up to 10 mice or
we can graft that tumor and we grow up a
large enough volume or mass of that
tumor that we can then archive it
for future use
now these archive tumors then can be
used to create any number of different
mice very often we work with
pharmaceutical companies that are
testing drugs or combination of drugs
and there
will perhaps need 100 or 200 mice with
the same tumor in that so we grow those
from these donor mice
usually at the p3 or p4 level as passage
3 or passage 4. we can grow up to a
couple hundred mice and then those are
ready for any type of drug efficacy
studies
now in terms of the sources of these
tumors as i said we've established quite
a network uh i think early on we worked
a lot with uc davis because we are
located close to them but we've expanded
now into more than 20 different cancer
centers
these cancer centers are sending us
directly from the operating room both
liquid and solid tumors and along with
those we get a lot of the de-identified
patient identification such as the age
of the patient the treatment history etc
we also uh when we can we do receive the
histology
uh of it so we can compare the histology
of a patient tumor to the tumor once
it's been in the mouse
but typically in terms of experimental
work these are used for compound
efficacy studies that is testing single
agents or combination agents
in a very defined tumor with very
defined genetic character
characteristics
i will say that many of these studies
are are take place actually at our clia
lab in sacramento we have a variety of
surgeons and phd scientists that support
this
activity now where we are today this is
a little out of date but we have
somewhere between 350 and 400 of these
pdx models that we have validated
characterized
archived
and established for uh for use by the
research community you see it really
varies the type of tumors we have
bladder tumors brain tumors
a few endometrial tumors etc but uh our
goal here is to keep building and
working with the research community to
have a really comprehensive resource of
different tumor types with different
genetic characteristics
and all those data that we collect then
we make available
freely with free access to the research
community and this is one of the areas
that really sets the jackson laboratory
apart from other
people other
suppliers of pdx models is everything we
have we make a freely available to the
public in something called the
most the mouse tumor database this is
through the access to the jackson
website
and there's an area uh you can just
click on pdx tumor search
and you can search the entire database
by the tumor identifier the primary
tumor site the for example being a lung
tumor the diagnosis and very importantly
the gene variant so if you're looking
for a specific
mutation that a target a therapy is
targeted to
this database allows you to find
multiple models typically with a
specific genetic mutation for those drug
testing studies
so if i click on in this case a bladder
tumor example you see what comes up here
is an entire list of different tumors
that are available in the database with
patient information and also um some
information on the genetic makeup of the
tumor if i pick one of these
and click on it
and we dig down deeper and really see
what's available for each of these
tumors that is there's a patient
information
there are gene
uh
excuse me copy number variation gene
varied information growth characteristic
characteristics and all the genomic
information we have so again you can
just go publicly available website at
jackson laboratory and and review all
this information
uh also connected with each tumor we we
have what's shown here is the gene
expression it's called the z number
whether it's an over express or under
expresser of specific genes
and we also make available something
called copy number variation that looks
at the representation of specific genes
in the genome whether there are
more copies than normal or fewer copies
than normal
another aspect of our program here which
is quite unique is the way that
researchers can access these models
we provide and we're really one of the
only uh laboratories that provide what
are called study ready cohorts that is
these are mice that we have engrafted
with tumors characterized and we will
ship to any researcher that allow them
to do drug efficacy studies or other
basic biology studies so any of the
solid tumors we have in the tumor
database
we have some aml models that are very
popular that's acute myeloid leukemia
these are engrafted with
myelo leukemia cells that are isolated
from individual patients and are used to
develop anti-leukemia drugs
and we also have a very popular language
called humanized nsg mice these are mice
that have been engrafted with human
hematopoietic stem cells and develop
human immune systems for infectious
disease research the sort of a sister
product line
in addition to providing these
study-ready cohorts to investigators we
also can do drug efficacy testing at our
clia facility here in sacramento and we
do
quite a volume of business working with
biotech and pharmaceutical companies and
some academics as well to test new drugs
and we have a new program that's shown
here the third thing called pdx live
and this is a way of taking the most
popular tumors and making them available
to uh researchers quickly one of the
traditional problems with pdx and models
is it takes quite a while to take a
a
tumor from the freezer thought and
grafted and grew up a cohort it can take
several months to generate the mice
needed for a study and with pdx live
what we've done is taken the most
popular tumors
some for example some of the breast
colon and lung tumors that are very
widely used and we maintain those mice
on the shelf and so very often you can
get the cohorts of mice within a week
days weeks or
maybe at most a few weeks not having to
wait for the months that it
traditionally took
now in terms of areas where we're strong
i think one of the big areas is a
non-small cell lung cancer what was
shown here is a panel of the non-small
cell lung cancer models that we
routinely work with and make available
and you see we have a lot of information
about the patient background
and the genetic makeup of the tumor and
the genetic makeup of the of the pdx and
basically most of the driver genetic
mutations that are of interest in
research are available from our
resource
we've also taken pains to be
deep in this area of triple negative
breast cancer when i say triple negative
that means is estrogen receptor negative
progesterone receptor negative and her2
new receptor negative
and this is important clinically because
these tumors
are troublesome to treat typically have
to be attacked with combination therapy
and our very active area of research
for new therapeutics and so
we have
established this panel here we're going
through a lot of the standard of care
drug studies on these now and looking to
expand this even further
now i mentioned the the estrogen
receptor negative
breast cancers on the last slide what's
shown here are a couple of receptor
positive
tumors on the left we see an estrogen
receptor positive
tumor and on right a progesterone
receptor positive tumor
the importance here is these estrogen
receptor example positive tumors
typically would not grow in mouse models
because they're dependent on human
estrogen for their growth
and
a lot of the previous mouse
models would not tolerate
the presence of the human estrogen they
would develop crystals in their bladder
etc now we found that the human
the that the human excuse me the nsg
mouse is very good at tolerating uh the
presence of estrogen and in fact we
typically implant a small capsule of
estrogen
in the neck the neck of the of the mouse
and it does support the growth of these
estrogen receptor positive tumors a very
um
sort of unique
niche for this model
i want to talk now about the structural
fidelity of these tumors because it's
really quite fascinating
and remarkable i think what's shown here
are some histology slides from a colon
adenocarcinoma
and this is a k-ras mutation a very
common driver gene
in colon other types of
carcinoma
on the left
slide or photo you see the patient tumor
histology
uh in the middle you see the p0 or first
passage of the tumor through a mouse
histology and secondly the p1 the second
passage of the tumor and what's
remarkable you'll see here are these
crypt-like structures that are very um
indicative of the adenocarcinoma type of
histology so you see that these uh
structures developed with remarkable
fidelity uh at multiple passages in
these pdx models
also shown here are two histology
sections of a colon adenocarcinoma from
a metastatic growth that is taken from
the lung and we see on the left this is
the patient histology
on the right we see after the first
passage through a mouse and again the
characteristic glandular structures that
you'd expect to see in an adenocarcinoma
are very faithfully recapitulated in the
mouse model
sticking with adenocarcinoma this is an
example
of a non-small cell lung adenocarcinoma
and the point here is really of
to focus on the gene expression data
we see the histology here of the
patient tumor the passage zero the
passage one and the passage two with the
recapitulation of again the glandular
type of histology
but this tumor
gene expression data shows first that
it's a k-ras mutant so k-ras is probably
a driver gene in this and it's shown to
be egfr wild type
and the importance there is there are a
variety of different uh therapeutic
agents that target mutant egfr
and so if we look at this tumor
our patient we'd expect for those
uh therapeutics that target mutant egfr
not to work
things like erlotinib and in fact when
we test this tumor that's exactly what
we see
what's shown here in the black line is
the vehicle control
and this is a growth curve
what's shown in the blue line is that
same tumor treated with aerolotinib
which targets the the mutant egfr we see
essentially no impact of that drug
because this tumor does not have the
mutation
but when treated with cysts platinum is
a red line we see it does respond so
the point here is these pdx tumors have
been shown to be
really remarkably good at predicting
therapeutic outcome and which drugs will
work and which drugs won't at recent
conferences i've been to
the number is typically that for the
older models such as the nude mice with
cell lines the protective power is only
about 30 percent
so it's not that much better than random
sometimes but these pdx models are often
are seeing greater than 90
uh predictive power
for the the use of drugs and this is
really what's gotten the oncology
community very very excited about these
models
the other very exciting thing about
these models is what you can do with
them in terms of studying different
drugs
you can really evaluate everything
that's available
by creating enough mice and designing
the right study things you could never
even dream of doing in a human setting
so you can rank order the efficacy of
single agents
very exciting you can study different
drug combinations
not only drug combinations but the
timing that is drug a first followed by
drug b
or maybe you'll try but drug b for
first followed by drug a and this let
you let you really kind of probe into
the onset of resistance and how the
drugs can interplay so uh really a
fascinating tool for studying the
interplay between different drug and
dosing regimens for individual tumors
i'm going to change gears now and talk
about liquid tumors and this is an area
where the nsg host has been a real
superstar so very often you cannot these
liquid
things like leukemias have not taken
very good hold in different mouse models
they really work very well with the nsg
host
and in these models what we do is we
engraft these mice with leukopharesis
samples so these are samples of cells
that are isolated from individual
leukemia patients
preserved and then injected into mice to
create these models
and the two models that we work most
commonly with one is called an uh flit
or flt3 itd
this is
a
it's basically a growth factor receptor
uh and it's muta this itd this internal
tanning repeat is one of the most common
if not the most common mutation seen in
aml patients
secondly is something called an idh1
mutant idh1 and idh2
they're actually
metabolic enzymes and when they're
mutated like this
they
interfere with the normal
differentiation of cells and so
the two models i'll talk about today and
what we most commonly sell
are the flip 3itd models and the idh1
mutant models
to create these is actually a quite a a
simple process we take the mice
we do a whole body irradiation which
create let's sort of opens up a niche in
the cells in them
opens up a niche in the um bone marrow
of the mice we can then inject these
human leukemia cells they will take hold
in the
bone marrow and other places
about 12 or she's about 14 to 28 weeks
and as we monitor those we see the human
aml cells appearing in the peripheral
blood and in other organs as well
this is an example here of
where we find these
these populations of the human
aml cells so on the left side we see two
different models
uh in terms of where the
the percentage of cells in the blood at
different time points we see the cells
in the spleen at different time points
and in the bone marrow so
you really do see these cells
proliferate as you'd expect a leukemia
to do in a human setting and we also see
these models responding to standard of
care drugs exactly like you'd expect a
human aml patient to respond in this
case the drug is called era c it's a
standard of care for many amls and we'll
see the decrease on the left here of the
number of aml cells in the bone marrow
of these models
we see a decrease in these cells in the
spleen
these models and also in the peripheral
blood so again therapeutically
the cells in the mouse model respond
exactly as you'd expect the cells to
respond in a human model
now i'm going to conclude now by talking
about sort of where the future of this
work is going
and
uh it really has to do with
excuse me again um
the human immune system and how the
human immune system is going to be can
be modulated
i think the most uh
active area of cancer research right
right now is human immuno modulatory
therapy
where you
modulate the human immune system to
attack the tumor itself
and well i'll talk about now conclude
are different models
that we are moving toward
uh for modeling
human immunotherapy
and that begins with something we call
the the humanized nsg or in this case
the cd 34 plus humanize nsg what we're
going to do here is create a mouse
that has the human immune system
as a first step
so again we create these models exactly
as we created the human aml models that
is by irradiation of the mouse to create
a niche in the bone marrow
in this case we're going to engraft
human hematophytic stem cells
and then out after several weeks we see
the appearance of human b cells human t
cells and most of the component of human
immune cells that you would typically
see
there are several different models of
this
that display different levels of human
immune function the most common is the
so-called cd34 humanized mice these are
created as i just said by engraftment of
human hematopoietic stem cells
these have a full range of human immune
cells uh with some exceptions but the
big thing here they have a very long
healthy lifespan many months
and uh so it can be used for very long
studies
the downside of these they do have
somewhat weak b cell function
and poor igg function so if you're in a
system where you need uh you need that b
cell function or more igg production
you might consider something that's
called the blt humanized mouse which is
based on the cd34
but has
the difference being we do implant small
pieces of liver
and thymus under the kidney capsule of
these mice and what that does it helps
with the t cell maturation and we do get
improved immune function in these cells
for certain things like mucosal immunity
if you're studying hiv infection in the
body you don't see any coastal immunity
in the cd34 cells you do definitely see
it in the blt mice
the downside of having the more souped
up immune system though is the mice do
not live as long these typically last
about 20 weeks and they develop a graft
versus host type of of
phenotype so improved immune system
life span a little bit shorter
also available or something called pbmc
humanized mice we basically take the nsg
mouse and just engraft the full
complement of pbmcs from a human
directly into the mouse
the upside of these is they do have the
full complement of human immune cells
but again you do have the short life
span and after about 30 days those cells
then will turn around the mouse and you
get this graph
versus also so depending on the type of
what you're studying
there are a variety of different options
here
and all these options are being looked
at today in the very early stages
to see if these can be models for
immunotherapy in the future that is
uh you know they're used for infectious
diseases shown on this slide they're
used for to study gene therapy and et
cetera but they can really be used to
study cancer we're hoping
because
if you can take an individual mouse and
grafted both with human immune system
cells and with human tumor cells i think
it's going to open some fantastic areas
for research
and this is just my concluding slide
today uh showing that that what
the areas where these humanized mice are
are really moving forward and the third
point is what i want to talk about these
human immuno-oncology models
is really our focus moving forward and i
think you'll see the field move very
aggressively to these new type of
pdx models very soon now
so i want to thank you for joining me i
hope i provided a good overview of the
field of pdx work and i'd be very happy
to take any questions now submitted
through your chat window
oh and i do have some now i figured out
the first question has to do with pdx
live uh it says how long will these
tumor models
uh maintain
their original traits
for on the shelf i think it basically
has to do with the stability of these
models
with the pdx live
what we do is we always try to go back
to the original tumor and so we maintain
those at early passage that is the
typically a passage three or passage
four so as long as we have the stocks on
the tumor they always go back to that
early stage that that we have found to
be optimal for demonstrating the proper
heterogeneity and
genetic characteristics of a human tumor
second question
uh the nsg mice are there nsg mice that
will develop drug resistance
and can they be used to uh over to study
overcoming resistance
uh
i will say that there are certainly
pdx implanted nsg mice
that are being used today
to study
drug resistance
they do they do actually can develop
resistance and can be used to study drug
resistance there are a number of
studies going on uc davis looking at
exactly that they have a very active
study
program in bladder cancer colon cancer
lung cancer and this is one of the areas
that they're investigating today
i'd be happy to take more questions
those are the two that came in so far
well if there are no more questions i'll
sign off i'll thank you for your
attendance today
and
feel free to contact me directly if
if possible so i'm signing off now thank
you